if you feel like you're a woman and
everyone around you is just constantly
saying biological biological name
biological man doctors doctors what
that's different
i mean okay sorry let me rephrase that
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the final installment of
my change my mind trilogy biological men
should not compete in women's sports in
part one we sat down with isaac and
although we had major disagreements he
proved to be articulate respectful as
you saw in part two we all endured a
very dark middle chapter filled with
deception regret and smug journalism
well today's third act find redemption
for humanity or will we once again find
ourselves assailed by activist cartoon
characters and army surplus jackets with
nothing to lose but their dignity
meaning nothing to lose well here we go
[Music]
our first conversation again at unt
today was between me and a student named
hugh here's hoping our conversation is
more constructive than the one we had in
part two
so
phew thanks for sitting down brother uh
i'll hold it just because some people
try and steal expensive microphones yeah
i get it you know just had someone run
by and try and throw a milkshake who i
believe was
i believe was a woman though it wasn't
very ladylike but uh it's a waste of a
damn milkshake you ask me i don't know
if it's a milkshake i don't know if it's
a frosty i don't know if it's some kind
of a uh sorry we just have to we're
running you know every now and then a
milkshake can contain concrete or acid
because you know yeah today's modern
left is so tolerant uh we have to run
into this i'm not saying you i'm just
saying this is what we run into on
campus so i get it uh hugh thanks for
sitting down i don't know how familiar
you are with kind of what this is at all
or what the program is let me kind of
give you the brief uh version it's just
a way for people to sit down and
hopefully rationalize their positions on
what are often seen as controversial
topics
um
often we are successful with that so
today obviously and this is sort of
something we had planned before but now
that leah thomas just won the uh
you know at ncaa uh the women's
championship one one of the races
i do not believe that biological men
biological males should be allowed to
compete
in women's sports uh
hugh if you disagree
with me much as why i assume you're
sitting down feel free to make your case
and change my mind so uh i disagree i
believe that
for one thing i don't think it should
matter i think it should be about the
sport i think if you're passionate about
the sport uh and you're into
you know like swimming or into whatever
it shouldn't really matter but there is
definitely something to be said about
can i ask you something real quick just
before what do you mean it shouldn't
matter so it meaning
i don't think it should make a
difference whether or not you have a
penis or whether or not you have a
vagina
whether or not you participate in
women's or men's sports so you just
believe that there should be no
divisions at all it should just be all
men and women compete against each other
not quite so so here's what i think okay
so it doesn't matter so
my position's a bit a little bit more
nuanced than that
i'm sorry if you're born with a penis
right
and you start taking hormone therapy it
changes the way your muscles
grow right so like after a couple of
years or after a couple of months you
know you're
on
estrogen your muscles
change and they start growing like you
know female muscles do and you're not
actually given that much of an advantage
or you're not they don't have as much of
an advantage as you think they might
yeah are you sure about that well i
guess i'm not sure but i also not sure
about anything because i'm not [ __ ]
you know
um
don't start it off that way then why are
you sitting down well they already know
yeah but i don't know that i don't know
what it's not fair for me to beat up on
a quote unquote [ __ ] [ __ ]
i don't have scientific peer-reviewed
studies at my back to you know quote
that's just
as i understand you take these hormones
it changes the way your body works your
body becomes more feminine you lose that
you know masculine muscle mass that you
might have and so after a couple of
months of hormone therapy a couple
months or a year it doesn't make that
much of a difference okay
now now what if that was entirely
incorrect if that were entirely
incorrect then yeah
that would be diff that'd be completely
different but then i think we need to
re-evaluate so let's say it's entirely
incorrect it would be different you mean
that
males should compete with biological
males and biological males compete with
biological females assuming that just a
couple months or even a year even two
years of the hormone replacement therapy
doesn't make that much of a difference
if it doesn't make that much of a
difference i think that
you could make that argument but i also
think that it's more it doesn't make
much of a difference it doesn't make
much of a difference
two two reasons why yeah
and they're gonna go to a separate
argument but i want to kind of hold you
to what you just said because i think
maybe we
agree
uh because this is something a lot of
people don't know they've done these
studies they've conducted them and i
always make all the references available
on the website as this goes up
after a year so two points after a year
of hormone replacement therapy hormone
suppression specifically for a man from
a man to a woman
they lose about five percent
of their total
strength
muscle density uh actual volume of
muscle okay
there are also other benefits that
remain so first off test it's not about
testosterone when you're taking it
testosterone in utero and testosterone
specifically through puberty
it's not just muscle strength anyone
who's done strength trending or sports
nose there's okay there's muscle there's
muscle volume there's muscle strength
there's muscle density there's fast
twitch muscle fibers there's slow twitch
muscle fibers there's anaerobic capacity
there's vo2 max there's lung capacity
there's bone density there's red blood
cell count there's uh connective tissue
strength ligament strength which is
about 80 percent higher in men and those
are not reversible as a matter of fact
even after an entire year after two
years after a year it's five percent
about of a loss five percent it's not a
big loss
and you see that by the way with let's
use leah thomas as an example and have a
second point
if you look at leah thomas the man who
just won the uh the females uh swim meet
the 200 meter 500 meter placed fifth and
won one of the other ones those times
wouldn't have even placed
top 500 or top 800. talking about
national beat the olympic silver
medalist wouldn't even place top 500
against men
reduce that by five percent is still not
even close
uh so okay they still have an
unbelievable advantage that's why we
have men's and women's sports right to
try and keep it fair and for the safety
of the players
second
um
not only that uh you were saying if if
if
your second point there was i'm trying
to remember what it was so my second
point is that it should be more about
the sport i think oh and also i should
also mention sorry that's what i was
thinking about is we have these
different studies also the ioc doesn't
require any hormone replacement therapy
whatsoever yeah that's kind of that
that's different i think
the big problem right now with
we just don't know enough
there's going to be a lot of
experimenting with trying to figure out
whether or not trans people can
you know how to include them in these
sports how to include them in these uh
in these activities in these
competitions but not experimenting at
the cost of biological females no that's
definitely i i think if that's the case
it's messed up but also okay mistakes
happen i think that well there's
difference between mistakes happening
right and thrusting them upon right
women because i'm sure that obviously i
would imagine on college campus
at least somewhat of a feminist you
support women's equal rights yeah yeah
certainly women's right to compete
fairly and safely right we both would so
let's not thrust an experimentation upon
women when all the empirical and
anecdotal data that we have thus far
shows it's unfair to them there's a
difference between mistakes happen right
well i don't
i haven't looked at all the data i
haven't checked out all that stuff i
can't say whether or not that's true or
not i do believe you though i think if
that's the case yeah it's totally unfair
they should totally uh okay they should
totally fix that they should totally you
know do whatever they need to do
do whatever they need to do to make it
fair for everyone competing i also just
what we've always done which is
biological males compete with males and
biological females compete with females
but i also don't think it's fair i also
don't think it's fair to
exclude them and that's also different
you know you said yourself well no one's
excluding sorry well
if you have you know
people with penises if we have a penis
division and we have a vagina division
isn't doesn't that mean that the trans
athletes in the male the
male division and the female division
are at a diff a disadvantage naturally
or also what about the other way around
if you have um you know someone with a
penis taking uh taking or something
suppressing if you have someone with a
vagina taking testosterone yeah and they
compete in the female division
more of an advantage yes taking steroids
right it's illegal already right it's
already so in other words these issues
already exist if you're a male you can't
compete with biological females and if
you're a biological female you're not
allowed to take steroids keep those
rules and why don't we have a third
division for everyone to compete i mean
why don't we have a i'm on board how
about that would that be fair i think
that would be fair i think that'd be
cool i just think it's like third
division a third division would be great
even a fourth and a fifth or fifty
fourth because they're you know
nine why not yeah who cares okay so i
think here's the thing you just said
you're an idiot yeah you actually have
uh maintained the most terrible position
you have today
let me explain and i mean that i'm not
just i'm not just you know shining your
ass here uh i don't know why anyone
would shine anyone's ass i don't know
why that's an expression you ever had
your ass shined get a good ass shining
today you go to the train station do
your shoes
no but um
sex the argument that's presented on
campus right and i don't really agree
with this that sex and gender are
different because it's a very modern
theory and gender was a grammatical term
but i think we would both agree that
what is taught as transgenderism is sex
is biological gender is societal right
gender is social that's the current
status of
that's what's being taught today in
gender studies okay
[Music]
it's not a position that can be
uh argued if you say gender and sex are
different to then say also you can
identify as a biological female what you
just said is actually remarkably
consistent that okay have a third
division because this is a gender issue
it's not a biological issue and like
you're saying as though even though it
sounds absurd to you and it sounds
absurd to me if you say 69 however many
genders the truth is if gender is
separate from sex
then we would have to maintain that
sports
male female men's women's divisions are
separated by sex by biology it's the
only fair way to do it it's the only
fair shake that women get and then if
people identify as a different gender
i'm fine doing a third category and i'm
genuinely i'm okay doing a fourth and
fifth category if they want to do that
so we say that's that's a fair
compromise yeah i think that's i mean
it's honestly it should be more about
the sport you know it should be about
the integrity of the activity that
you're doing it should be about the
athletes it should be about the people
who actually care about it you know
it shouldn't just be about trying to win
like and granted i don't think that you
know leah thomas or whatever i don't
even honestly i don't follow sports i
didn't even know that you know that was
happening uh but it it's not about just
you know trying to get a gold medal you
know it's about swimming it's about it's
about moving your damn arms in the water
it's about kicking your legs
it shouldn't be about what sports are
about winning i mean sport yes sports
are definitely about winning but it
should be about the competition it
should be about you know
the the integrity of the sport and as
long as that's being maintained i agree
that's cool but there's no integrity in
beating up on women exactly but we need
to find a way to include trans people in
that we need to find a way to encourage
them in that because honestly they just
want to live their lives they just want
to compete in these sports like anyone
else and if they don't have an outlet to
do that if the only way that leah thomas
can compete
and feel like herself is by uh is by
competing in the female division well
then yeah it is a little it isn't fair
but it's also unfair to her to say you
know what you can't compete sorry all
your your life as a swimmer is over your
life as an athlete is it unfair is it
unfair to a heavyweight to say you can't
compete at bantamweight biology is
biology and sports are separated by
biology that's not unfair it would be
unfair to say you can't eat at a diner
it'll be unfair to say you can't rent at
this apartment because you're trans it's
not unfair to say you can't compete in
the biological women's division and we
just made a lot of progress now you're
going back on it so
a different gender division i agree with
no so what i
it's a little bit different i think than
saying having a heavyweight compete in
you know a featherweight because
trans people they're by a lot they're
biologically different i mean if we're
talking about bio if we're talking about
biology when you take these hormones it
does have an effect on your body but
there isn't even a trans you know there
isn't even a there isn't a leave for
leah thomas so what what what should she
have well there is a league for leah
thomas it's the men's swimming division
but that's not quite true thomas wasn't
that good
i mean thomas is a male 1 i don't
believe he attends a biological male 1
leah thomas was born with a penis and
that would mean yes biologically
that she was born leah thomas was born
with a penis and xy chromosome leah
thomas had more testosterone and overall
overall sex hormones in utero leah
thomas went through puberty which
defines bone density defines ligament
strength defines vo2 max defines red
blood cell count defines contractile
strength of muscular tissue leah thomas
went through all of that and leah thomas
was competing as a male up until only a
couple years ago just like fallon fox
was a male who fathered children and
then two years later shattered a woman's
orbital bone come on that's not
happening no but it's not quite fair to
say that she is
biologically just as male as you or me
right because after taking action
after taking estrogen after taking all
that stuff it did affect you i mean you
said it yourself right there's at least
a five percent change right
which is far less than the difference
between for example a heavyweight and a
light heavyweight the point is the
difference is so radical
it's so radical between come on this is
one thing too we both between men and
women there's a reason the difference
between men and women but i think
there's also a radical difference
between trans women and biological men
and people who are biological men that
identify as biological
no
no one's argued that up until very
recently do you believe that someone who
identified so if tomorrow i start
identifying as a woman
you believe that biologically i'm
different than most of the men here no
but i think you'd be an [ __ ] because
that's not that's not how transgenderism
works yes it does that's exactly what's
happened that's what happened with mary
gregory a female powerlifter that's what
happened with janae crock a female male
to female powerless there's a
documentary on it on amazon called
transformers a transformer yeah michael
bay crappy one transformers transformer
is what i believe it is was uh matt
krakazinski some polish name i can't
pronounce then became janae marie
and dominates
in women's divisions you see this with
female power lookers you see it with
male to female transgender power lifters
you see it in cycling records being set
yes i could do that i could in one
year's time
it would be the exact same scenarios
leah thomas identifies a woman and in
many sports
two weeks time
according to the international olympic
committee i wouldn't have to undergo any
hormone replacement therapy at all and
just say i'm a woman
what's how how do you know well then
that that's just something that needs to
be regulated that's just a rule that
needs to be added that's something that
needs to be uh accounted for but i also
think it's it's a little disingenuous to
say oh yeah i i'm a man and now tomorrow
i'm a woman and i'm going to compete in
these women's sports because that's not
exactly what leah thomas did i don't
think that's exactly what the thomas did
i don't know in the biological frame of
reference yes but there's leah thomas
there's a lot more to sports and there's
a lot more to life than just biology and
what about social media no not to sports
to sports it's about winning and it's
about and if we separate them by biology
you may not like it but that's why we
separate them i don't think that's and
that's why i think we both agreed before
if they want to have a third to keep it
fair and to keep it safe
we can have sports based on
additional genders right but have the
traditional the original sports of male
and female which is separated by biology
to be fair just like late classes just
like age brackets and then if someone
wants to identify a different way we say
well in order that we protect women
right and also you not feel marginalized
you can compete in a third division well
i think that's where that's where this
disconnect is i still believe that i
absolutely believe that but i also don't
think that there's no way that a trans
athlete can compete right now in a trans
division and so for leah thomas i i feel
bad for her because if she wants to
compete she can't come there's no
transiting for her to compete so she
hasn't do you feel bad for the woman
who she the all the women who leah
thomas do you feel bad for the 80 plus
women who have now lost out on
scholarships and international rankings
of course i feel bad for them but i feel
just as bad for them as i do leah thomas
because you know what at the end of the
day i don't know any of those women just
like i don't know leah thomas and i
think that we should consider everyone's
ability to compete we should consider
everyone's you know so much solution
well the solution is for this thomas
situation wow
i'm not i'm not involved in swimming i
don't know if they need to have a
different what's the solution for
men and women's sports male and female
sports which has always been separated
by biology it cannot be changed no
matter how many hormones you take
the solution continue going with what we
have done to ensure the safety and equal
opportunity of women that's why title ix
exists or offend all of it so that we
don't hurt some people's feelings well
no
it's not just black it shouldn't be so
black and white it shouldn't just be
this or that then what is a solution a
solution have a transit first of all
have a trans league have more divisions
where more people can compete why don't
we just have an augmented league where
you can have robot legs you know let's
just see how far we actually do have
that we actually do there was a guy who
had a south african who had no legs and
he had those bent back paper clips that
he ran on and then he killed his
girlfriend
yikes um what i mean i mean you know
i think i remember that story i don't
remember that story
but i was running around it looked like
it was running around looked like he was
looked like he was from that uh
uh sector nine movie like those prawn he
was running around these these little
like bent back metal paper clips and
then people were complaining they had an
unfair advantage and they're like well
he doesn't have any legs it's like well
yeah but those are basically mechanical
at that point but then also if he wanted
to compete how could he he there's no
you know mechanical family to compete
you know you don't get to
that's kind of lame i just think i think
that's lame to the sport that's lame to
the activity you know that's that's that
does a disservice to people who want to
participate in this i want to set a
bench press record
can i do it with a i want to set a world
bench press record can i use a crane
well it's not i don't think
i think you're going about the sport
wrong if you're just trying to break a
record because there's a lot more
involved in you know breaking records
not to these women who are afforded
scholarships and coaching jobs right
we would have to acknowledge that's
important this is it's not fun to be an
ncaa you know it's not fun to be a
silver medalist at the olympics like the
lady had to play second it's a tough
tough life right and then you're ripping
it from them because someone who was a
middling to low-end male swimmer decided
i'm gonna be a woman next to you
i i don't think that's fair and i don't
think it's looking out for the best
interest of women um
i don't think it's it's you're talking
so much about women and you're talking
so much about the rights of these people
but what about you know the trans people
do not do they not also have rights or
they're not also human humans that you
don't have a right
i mean i don't think that it's a right
to
that's what we're talking about if we're
just talking about sports yeah it's a
little unfair if they want to take a
dump at a target and a moo moo with some
eye makeup i don't care but it's the
the hatred with which you speak about
them
what hatred
the way
that you talk about them doesn't it's
not respectful how have i spoken about
them that's disrespectful i just don't
think they should be allowed to beat up
on women or beat women at sports no
that's fair but there's a there isn't is
there not an underlying like what do you
think about trans people as a group do
you do you hate them it sounds like no i
don't really i'm not i don't i don't
know you but it's personal i don't hate
them no i don't hate them at all
i feel i feel very uh i feel sorry for
many of them
in what way do you feel sorry for that
well i think that we're dealing uh with
a demographic that now we're getting off
of the topic here uh but i think we're
dealing with a demographic that has a 19
times the suicide rate of the general
population that's a 42 attempted suicide
rate and
i don't think that um denying the
realities the constraints of biology
and the human condition is helping them
i think that we're actually
uh putting many of them and especially
when you involve uh hormone replacement
therapy and when we know what estrogen
does to the male body when we know what
estrogen excess estrogen does to the
female body
we are in an attempt to coddle them
uh rather than seek
assisting them
we're putting them into a shallow
young cancerous grave
so then do you think that transgender or
being trans is a disease more than it is
a lifestyle choice no i don't i don't
think it's a disease i think that um you
would have to look at a very very strong
not only correlation but causation
because you would look at both pre and
post-op the suicide rate doesn't improve
right the attempted suicide is about
41-42 pre-op it's about 41 42 percent
post-op the mental health issues are
through the roof
uh the regret uh upon transitioning even
though very few of them actually do go
through with the bottom surgery even
hormone replacement therapy is very very
hot so uh i think we have to look at
that and say okay why is this happening
in this community and how do how do we
actually more effectively address that
than just say
however you identify compete that way
and we used to say gender and sex were
different but now we'll allow them to be
one of the same in sports i don't think
it's productive well
it honestly for me it breaks my heart
because i think about the fact that you
know the suicide rate is super high so
many of them are killing themselves why
do you think that is so unhappy part of
that's because society hates them
because of the way that so many people
treat them i mean if you feel like
you're i think that's part of it i think
there's certainly a mental health aspect
of it but i also think that
if you feel like you're a woman and
everyone around you is just constantly
saying biologically biologically
biological man doctors doctors what
that's different
i mean okay sorry let me rephrase that
i don't
think that
it's fair to only think about
the rights of
women in sports without also talking
about trans mental health i mean there's
so much that goes into all of these
issues no i agree i agree but i think
they're separate issues i think that
biological men we both agree biological
males should not be allowed to compete
with biological females and sure we can
address them address the mental health
issues you know it's interesting that
you bring up i i don't agree with the
premise that's because society hates
them
i don't agree with it because matter of
fact minorities in this country uh
minorities historically have a lower
rate of suicide right black people have
a two and a half times lower rate of
suicide than white individuals suicide i
don't know if you know is almost
entirely a middle-aged white male
problem
um also i don't believe that they have
it worse than jews in auschwitz because
that's a 25 attempted suicide rate do we
believe that a transgender individual in
2022 because they can't set another
women's swim meet record
is going to attempt suicide because they
have a worse life than jews and
auschwitz they have a worse life they're
being treated worse in society than
american slaves
nowhere else
nowhere else can you find this high of
an attempted suicide rate
outside of people with severe
psychiatric conditions that we address
right and in this case we're saying well
no rather than addressing someone let's
say who's paranoid schizophrenic we're
going to say no those delusions are real
that's what we're doing right now that's
why the suicide rate is so high that's
why it doesn't get better after
treatment it's a it's a very
heartbreaking reality
we've tried it this way now for a couple
of decades and it hasn't yielded good
results it's yielded worse results so
then you do think that transgenderism is
a disease i mean or do you i think they
by their own by their own declarations
there is rampant mental health uh uh
there are rampant mental health issues
in the transgender community right they
have said that but you think it's a
disease you think it's something that
needs to be ironed out you think that
they just need to figure out how to live
how to feel happy i think that if
someone is biologically a male i think
right now you're a man right and i can
tell you're a man you can tell i'm a man
we don't need to do all the the
you know the college devil speak here i
think for you to look down right now at
your penis and for you to go through
with what it takes
to cut that off i want you to this is a
mental exercise i want you to think
about for a second
what kind of a mental place you would
need to be in to hate your penis so much
that you have it cut off and turned into
a non-functioning vagina for the rest of
your life which by the way will very
likely prevent you from ever achieving
sexual climax again
to think of the mental state that you
would have to be
genuinely put yourself there
that's not a healthy place to be
mentioned
i don't know if it's as black and white
as that i think there's a gray area
where
it's not just about you know cutting off
your penis it's about feeling better in
your own body it's about if you look at
yourself in the mirror you know and
and you know you you look at your [ __ ]
and you're like oh man i just i can't
live with this thing yeah i just it
doesn't feel like me it doesn't
who am i to say you know what you can't
go ahead cut it off i mean who are we to
stop them from doing that
i'm not saying you can't right i'm not
saying you can't i just don't think i
just don't think it's fair to
characterize it as hateful for me to say
that seems pretty severe
it it seems extreme but that also just
shows how uncomfortable they feel in
their body right now i mean
i can't imagine looking at myself every
day and just
not feeling like
myself i mean if you had to live every
day inside someone else's body and never
feel like yourself that's that's how
it's your own body well okay it is your
own you just believe in someone else's
you know changing your body getting
bottom surgery it's
it is a bad mental state but it's also
good we agree it's a bad mental state
but not in the same way that but it's
not and it's not corrected by going
through with the transition it gets
slightly worse
i think that's that's on an individual
case-by-case basis
i think it depends the attempted suicide
rate stays the same poster
and again it's double that of jews and
auschwitz
and i think that matters i think that
matters because people will throw out
the monikers you did you know hate
there's no hate
just like i've had people in my family
who you know struggle with severe
bipolar disorder
i don't hate them when i say look you're
not seeing things clearly i've had to do
that i've had to have interventions and
say this is not accurate
it's clouded by your
mental health condition not a disease
there's a difference between a
psychiatric condition and a disease
uh an actual disease state
um
and i think to mischaracterize that as
hate is also what creates this bully
pulpit that causes real harm to women in
women's sports and
look i think you care about people
uh i would
appreciate though i don't demand that
you maybe recognize that i do as well i
just have a different different approach
to it and different solution to it um
and i believe that
women need
to be defended just as much
just as much as other people do
and i think we agree on the
third division i i agree i don't think
that you're a hateful person but i think
that your efforts to help and
fix
the trans community are misguided and i
think that your efforts could be better
spent helping them in it with the
platform that you have with the audience
that you have
you could do so much to make their lives
better in a way that you know
in a way that doesn't you don't have to
advocate for them well i think they have
a pretty big voice right now as we see
women of the year right we have trans
there
female admiral not woman admiral female
admiral rachel levine just had a man
a transgender woman sorry biological
male transgender woman just win a medal
at the uh ncaa swim meet and today i'm
choosing to use my voice for the
overwhelming majority of female athletes
who often sort of get silenced that's
right but how often do you appreciate
them
to talk about suicide translated
i just did well i guess that i just did
that was through something else
yeah i just did what we've done that
we've done their only two genders change
my mind that's a separate discussion but
today we're specifically talking about
sports but thank you brother thanks
freezing get some hot facts or something
thank you
there you have it while you and i didn't
find a lot of common ground i appreciate
that he was able to actually sit down
and listen to an opposing point of view
while presenting his own if you want to
learn more about this channel's point of
view be sure to subscribe and most of
all just tune in to the daily show
monday through thursday live at 10 a.m
eastern they can't all be changed my
minds mostly due to the security costs
but live weekday morning shows is the
next best thing see you tomorrow back to
the topic at hand of course
the college campus is filled with many a
strange beast as you've all well seen
however there are a lot of great people
that come out to change my mind and this
day was no exception we came across a
number of kind and intelligent students
and some of them like this young lady
even offered some valuable insight hey
fair enough
thank you for your contribution
sweetheart next up and our final
interview we have our boy jackson let's
close this one on a strong note jackson
you don't know how familiar you are at
all with kind of what this segment is or
what it is that we do but it's not sure
the opportunity to hopefully rationalize
our positions and what are sort of
controversial topics what i've noticed
is people will often have rational
discussions on topics that are maybe
inconsequential than something that you
know evokes a visceral or emotional
response it goes out the window sure and
unfortunately on college campus
college campuses across the country you
often are only presented with one point
of view and so hopefully this allows
people to be able to expose themselves
to different points of view so today
obviously this is something we were
planning uh to talk about for uh a while
uh and then uh well we just had the ncaa
swim
meet this last weekend so now it's a hot
button issue
i don't believe
that uh
biological males should be allowed to
compete with women
in sports sure if you disagree with that
i'd love to hear your case you're more
than welcome to change my mind
i could try uh i find it interesting as
well that when you come to college's
campuses it is you know usually biased
in one direction in recent times this
campus has been a little bit more mixed
i'm sure you came here because of the
recent news
what do you mean it's biased in one
direction
usually a campus is depending on a
geographical location is going to be
biased in a political direction left or
right
what's always left
depends
what college campus would you give me an
example of that's
right i mean we're in texas man
yeah i can't think of one i mean the
only one i can think of really in the
country would be a m and even then when
you look at professors and stuff like
that and it's
conservative i i didn't mean to have to
but no no that's fine and i'm definitely
conservative but um
you know there's a large mass majority
of texas is you know country towns i
came from a little country town that my
high school graduation class was 200
people so it's like i gotta tell you
i've never gone to a college campus and
experienced conservative bias
statistically that is almost not exact
schools you get to go to because you
would love them like private christian
colleges i can imagine but public
schools public colleges really in the
state of texas that are conservatively
biased a m is definitely one
uh texas tech definitely one you know
raider rash is their thing so okay
either way that's besides the point no
no look
at that experience there's a lot of
people that think just like you well
that's not really where i go to visit
that's why visit places like ut and
places like unt there's uh
well ut's a little bit mixed too ut
austin ut austin is pretty liberal
yeah ut austin is pretty liberal no i
prefer to actually have conversations
with
uh people from opposing points of view
yeah um that's kind of
one of the things that we do
uh because i don't really like an echo
chamber left or right yeah so uh yeah i
know it would be really easy for me to
sit down with nothing but as a matter of
fact today we haven't had a single
conservative sit down and that's because
we give the right-of-way to people who
disagree conservatives here
there are yeah yeah now of course we're
not gonna have someone who tried to
throw a you know whatever
frozen latte or milkshake we're not
gonna yeah yeah right there you see oh
it's a waste of a good frosty
well either way i don't know if it's a
frosty or not but violently already no i
appreciate it i like a good conversation
well good so i'm sure you would condemn
the violence and the disruption as well
it definitely is not necessary yeah it's
not i don't even know what this guy's
doing either with a yoda thing
he's just doing him i don't know
that's definitely a probe
radical transliberation now means but
okay
yeah it doesn't mean that's well you
know x message
i appreciate
uh that you and i can find some common
ground on that i would almost argue it's
nonsensical a yoda mask and radical
transliberation now
i don't know what inference to make
and he won't speak so it's not like i'm
going to be able to figure it out he's
just doing it he's just well he's just
being a little bit of a
uh
but uh yeah i don't think the biological
male should be able to uh compete
with women biological women female
sports um
what do you disagree with on that and
how would you want to change your mind i
think as a whole that issue
uh
it's only in the current times you know
our world is changing every day and
especially on this campus you can see a
lot of different opinions and views and
different people doing what they want to
do
and i don't feel that that affects me in
any way and when it comes to sports it's
a little different
i think this time in history is very
special because we are so connected
we've been connected for a few decades
now but at this point really we're
exploring that connection even more what
do you mean by connected the internet
okay so just this connection i mean i
think it'll be a strong case that we're
not very connected i don't know if
you've been on twitter lately
i don't feel warmly connected to my
fellow man but no i agree with your
point not you know connected it doesn't
always have to be positive yes exactly
we can be connected and ask foolishness
yeah sure sure yeah free speech but
twitter's a little different either way
yeah i think
it's satan's rectum twitter
interesting okay well either way
figuratively
sports are are different i think this
time is everything is changing every day
i think sports at one point
there shouldn't be gender
involved i feel like it should just it's
not involved gender is not involved in
sports how do you mean
it's sex
yeah
are you saying that gender and sex are
the same thing no i misspoke but sure
i'll replace that well no i say it
because i
well i'm not trying to correct you i see
it because i see this you actually
actually um i appreciate that you're
being consistent because i have had
people sit down today
and say that uh sex and gender are the
same thing
i'm not 100 sure
the news is changing every day so
i'll go with sex for now
as long as well that's what gender
theory is right that's what modern
gender studies is and this goes back to
you know it goes back to school
volunteer sex is what goes through john
money judith butler and by the way these
people who believe that gender was a
social construct they still believe that
people could maybe be
men or women within the societal
contract but it was always within a
binary you're only talking about the
1990s when that changed this idea that
there could be many different genders
but even on this campus right now
in your gender studies classes
they teach that gender is societal
social construct and sex is biological
that is the current curriculum
interesting um and i just want to make
sure that we're clear on that i think i
think that what you were saying is is
consistent so i i actually do appreciate
that yeah i i consistently see this kid
i don't know either way sports right now
there's not a lot
there's a lot happening is what i'm
saying either way in a few years i'd
like to see just
not based on gender or sex or anything
it's just this is basketball we all play
you know what i mean
i know you might think i'm crazy but i
mean no i don't i just think that you
just ended women's sports forever no no
exactly not
the issue is
not in
the biological differences in the mail
yeah women wouldn't be able to compete
ever they would just lose at every sport
with the exception of shooting sports
i think there should be i'm not a
professional obviously i'm not well
versed in this field i'm not i'm only in
you know a few sports either way
this
this sports issue i feel like it's just
a
topic to grab on to
that are happening right the second but
it wouldn't be happening in a few years
maybe we would figure something else
what do you mean in a few years how
would we figure it out
in discussion here
well that's what we're having exactly
right now but you just
i'm not trying to be a smart ass here
but correct me for wrong i just heard
you say that it's just everyone playing
together sure yeah that's what i said
okay that's so that's what you think we
should move towards
and you understand that's an option
there are no more female athletes
i think
that male and female are equal i know
there are biological differences and
strength and that kind of thing well
that's what sports are about exactly i
understand that but
these sports aren't always going to be
you know the rules change every day that
kind of thing
yeah the mba's rules are not the same as
10 years ago 20 years ago there's new
rules at every point in time so i feel
like
we would be able to figure something
else out
it wouldn't just be one issue changing
at the same time we would combine the
sports there would also be new
legislation inside of the if that's the
right word for it inside of the nba or
any sports
category
to try and make it so that women could
compete
how would you for example let's take
the nfl
let's take i don't know if there is
women's contact football honestly there
is there is okay
um
let's take well you know what let me
take an example and not to be anecdotal
when i'm taking an example that has
actually taken place because there
haven't been that many you know intersex
sporting matches but what does take
place pretty regularly and it's a
non-contact sport soccer so the women's
uh national soccer champions have you
seen this no yes like the women's uh i
don't know if it's the national soccer
champions or like the women's world cup
winners will regularly play high school
boys and lose
so what rule sets
do you think you could rather than just
going with right what we have which is
male and female sports for the
safety and fairness of the players right
is to protect the players and to protect
that's their opportunity
well okay
what would we uh change as far as rules
that would somehow offer women who have
not only less strength not only less
muscle mass not only higher body fat not
only lower bone density not only 80
lower connective tissue strength not
only lower lung less lung capacity not
only lower vo2 max not only less a lower
red blood cell count
not to mention general height and
dimensions
what rule changes do you think could
possibly be implemented for example
in
soccer wrestling basketball football
swimming
that would allow an even playing field
for biological women i feel
i i like that you're trying to bombard
me with all these topics but i'll take
this one
we know that men no i know that men have
a significant do we disagree that
biological males have a significant
athletic advantage over biological
females as a general rule biological
male and female are separate they're
different
but that doesn't have to have to occur
i'm saying with time there could be
medical advancements to change how the
male and female bodies work how they
change how
the rule sets work i'm not one to say
well we have that now they're called
steroids
that's a little different that's not
yeah no it absolutely is that's exactly
what what biological females who are
claiming to be men that's exactly what
they're taking claiming
identifying men yeah they're taking
steroids
did you know that right yeah they take
hormones
as well as steroids but anabolic
steroids are illegal apparently right
i'm trying to make the point of in time
maybe they should all be legal and maybe
you know
again everyone is on steroids yeah i
mean they all die very young because of
cancer yeah i'm saying i'm not saying
the current steroids i i think you see
what i'm saying with time this could all
happen okay but we're today 2022 it's
not possible we just had someone who was
a biological male who is a middling to
low-end male swimmer
who just won first place who just beat
out a silver medalist
very hard to get a silver medal by the
way
beat a female silver medalist
with a time that wouldn't even rank top
500
against men the point you're making i
understand it completely
it would not apply in the future
it may not apply in the future but it
certainly applies today so what do we do
today can't do anything today there
would have at least i can
so but we agree then today that we need
to continue with ensuring the safety and
fairness for our players particularly
for female athletic opportunities
in states like california they're
assessing with marijuana use in
different areas and the state government
is governing that rather than federal
government the federal government is
letting it as a test run same kind of
thing sports right now it's kind of just
a test run we
you know no there's no offense to any
athletes whatsoever but everyone's
trying their best we always have yeah
but i feel that we got to have some test
runs to figure this stuff out we can't
just argue about it right now well i've
i understand what you're saying and i
appreciate your idea you know sort of
presenting the idea of federalism to
sports i actually
you know that's not lost on me uh that
being said we have the empirical
evidence you know evidence like i just
presented as far as the difference in
physiology that doesn't change maybe
many years from now it'll change when we
have you know george jackson can't do
anything right by the way his wife was a
horrendous she took his whole wallet
when he was giving her that cash he
takes all the takes the wallet and
doesn't even give him enough gas money
to get home especially now knowing what
we know about gas prices today what do
you think they're gonna be in the jets
in the future but i digress but um i
mean i'll let me judson i do too every
character i just don't even [ __ ] okay
well i think mrs jetson at the very
least she's pushing the envelope there i
think that's theft interesting uh and
also that robot made
that robot made i'm telling you it's the
future i mean if you're computer
we have no idea what's going to happen
tomorrow but uh we have no idea but we
know what's happening today so there's
the empirical data which is all these
differences that obviously uh the male
athlete benefits from biologically
that's undeniable um and then there's
the anecdotal
where we have the autonomous but that's
not the only example you have
men who've then switched biological
males have been switched to females
who've set records in cycling who've won
track right who've won
i think in track it's for example let's
say it's one percent of the population
it might be one to one point six percent
of the athletic student body that are
trans but they will in certain sports
dominate 66 percent of the top spots 90
percent in powerlifting right we had
that mary gregory was a power lifter set
these all-time records for women
uh there's cycling there's uh swimming
like we've just discussed there's pop
there's power lifting there's olympic
weightlifting laurel hubbard who made it
who won these uh these medals until
laurel hubbard made at the olympics and
then due to an injury had to pull out
and also was 43 which is not typical of
olympians there have been over 80
opportunities
meaning scholarships and international
rankings that have been yanked out from
under women today because of this new
experiment
we know that when you allow the
biological male to compete against
biological women that it's an unfair
playing field today that's not even
close there are obvious biological
differences i understand what you're
saying but i feel as if
these
whether or not they're
trans or not it's just a current day
issue okay i think you would agree but
it is a current day exactly what do we
do today
i can't stay here i don't know
what is the right thing to do the right
thing to do the right thing to do today
with male and female sports
i think i'll get to it real quick okay
the right thing to do it is obviously
complicated you know
no matter what you do you're going to
annoy someone i don't think it's
complicated i think i think the first
part is comfortable no i think you'll
annoy somebody but i don't think it's
complicated as far as the right thing to
do would you say that coming to an
agreement is always 100 one direction
wait what do you mean coming to an
agreement like say an election
it's not usually one way somebody's
going to be mad either way right
so in this way
we have to you know tread lightly to
figure out what would be capitulate to
less than one percent of the population
at the expense of fifty percent of the
population
less than one to fifty
yeah less than one percent being
transgender individuals
by switching up the way that we've done
sports again which exists
i can't confirm the statistic but
yeah the highest number i've ever heard
is one point six percent of the
population is trans sure
number let's call it one let's call it
one to two percent does that sound fair
i wonder i have no idea the statistics
but i'll give you a one to two spread
okay and some numbers are even lower
than that so i'm trying to pick the
number that i think is most generous one
point something percent
but 50 of the population
are females sure and 100
at least up until recently of female
athletic competitors
were biological females so to capitulate
here when we're trying to not offend one
point something percent of the
population
we are unfortunately short-changing 50
women who want to compete who they're
listen this affects
their lives right scholarships
getting a scholarship getting an olympic
medal getting a coaching job these
things have serious ramifications right
sport is a great way for people
particularly those of lower
socioeconomic status yeah exactly it
equalizes the playing field and now
we're making that unfair because a
certain very small percentage might be
offended this specific issue would be
best talked about by a female athlete or
just a female altogether i i'm a white
male i have you know i my input here is
not as valuable as a female athlete or a
female altogether no matter if they're
trans or not
you know what i actually agree with you
on that i actually well i don't agree
with you in that you can't have an
opinion i think you're in your opinion
depending sorry i just touched your leg
uh because it also gets warm obviously
the only warm thing around here where
are you guys usually based if i
interrupt first of all we're around
texas general area i actually you know i
keep it ghost-like
and by the way that dog is as cute as
cute as a button it's very distracting
to me right now um
what were you talking about this before
sorry that dog was just
what were we talking about that's a
problem with cute puppies
that's true they just distract me it's
right in my line of vision
the the marginal differences and then
comparing that
damn puppy ruined it for the rest of us
oh no you said that you were a white
male oh yes exactly i think that if your
uh opinion is founded on
sound research and data and it's you
know based in fact yeah i think i think
it doesn't matter if you're a white male
and it doesn't matter if you're a black
male doesn't matter if you're a black
female white trans i think
there's a correct opinion at the end of
the day and there's there's correct
information and there's incorrect
information and then sometimes you make
an inference based on that now i do
agree with you however
women in many cases particularly
feminists have said no vagina no opinion
and so they have marginalized the
opinions
uh of men on this issue which which is
interesting to me because there's kind
of a there's a pretty big spread
if you actually look at the polling data
and i usually don't like to point to
polls except in this scenario where
you're polling female athletes like
their opinions obviously matter
so if you look at men
generally speaking if you look at poll
after poll when they ask men should
biological males be allowed to compete
in
women's sports men overwhelmingly say no
which is interesting because we don't
really have a dog in that fight no
biological female has come over and
dominated the men's sports it doesn't
happen it's never happened
but overwhelmingly non-female athletes
have supported it saying sure because
women generally speaking are empathetic
people right they're understanding
people i think it's a great quality of
women that's a that's some form of bias
like i feel like i'm a very empathetic
person sure i think you are but i think
as a general rule women are more
conscientious
than most men
i i see what you mean but i don't agree
well i think if you look at the polling
you know men are more pragmatic in the
sense they go like well no that's not
fair men shouldn't be able to compete
against women so they oppose it then you
look at women who are not female
athletes they support it then you look
at the polling of female athletes
they're against it
because most of the feminists who say
biological men should be allowed to
compete in women's sports don't have a
dog in that fight all of a sudden when
you pull the female athletes it's very
different yeah i could see what you mean
but at the same time it
my point still stands i i am not you
know a woman and you're not a woman i i
don't think at least i wouldn't assume
and you did assume and you assumed
correct but okay either way
the the difference is
we
don't uh wake up every day as a female
we don't go through our lives getting
cat called for these kind of things
these horrendous things i'm sure you
have a wife or a girlfriend or something
and you hear you know it's not easy
sure and
my life's not that bad like i can't
complain yeah there's there's not a lot
of
things that i have to deal with because
i was born this way
there's
it's interesting seeing
was that a lady gaga reference
but i like the point though but either
way you know it's certain things like
this may sound stupid but i drive a
purple truck okay
you have a purple truck yeah
why is that stupid no i love my truck
it's not super point
that's interesting purple truck makes
you a pound
interesting okay okay either it was a
pimp color nothing wrong with that i
love it keep your pin pan strong man the
point i'm trying to make is
i get profiled for driving that vehicle
so in my little country towns you know
i'm profiled because that vehicle is
certain driven mostly by a certain type
of people who pimps
i don't know either way i get pulled
over and and wait are you saying that do
you get profile because they think it's
a black guy or because i think it's a
gay guy no it's definitely not a
either
either way on my ticket wait what do you
mean it's not any of those harry being
profile i don't understand listen on my
ticket yeah i get as a
as
you know they pull up to me and
everything they already write the ticket
out my race is incorrect every ticket
i've received
you know what race do they write
hispanic
oh
okay interesting so either way is it an
el camino no
that's a little interesting but uh why
is that issue i'm saying like i wouldn't
think i wouldn't because i wouldn't
think purple truck hispanic
you're not from bunch of towns
all right
i assume at least i don't know is it
like more of a moe are we talking like
full on like joker purple it's
completely deep purple
that sounds like a nice truck yeah it's
beautiful
either way
what i'm trying to say is
i can if i can make a comparison or a
metaphor some form my purple truck was
born how it is
born you know in a factory but
i get i i was i'm not complaining
whatsoever i do not mind but i i have
been profiled for that truck right
so if you can commit the comparison to a
female living in this world yeah you
know i i can't say for sure but you know
i've i've had girlfriends like it's not
easy and and even more so for someone uh
who is trans or someone who is
non-binary or someone who didn't see it
i was with you up until that last point
yeah because i agree
i agree with you that it's not easy yeah
and i don't think we should make it
harder on uh women by allowing
biological males to get the [ __ ] out
i feel that
people should be equal people can be
empathetic no matter their their sex
that people can be whoever they want to
be and i think that the current times
are are going to change yeah you know
people can't be whoever they want to be
or whatever they want to be i believe
they can there are biological and
physiological limitations to everybody
you know there's ethical differences as
some things like murder or you know
there are violence
there are biological realities there are
physical realities for example your
height is your height
uh your bone density is your bone
density you get a surgery to change your
height you can get a surgery to change
your height but again we're talking
about extreme exceptions to the rule the
general rule there are still and that by
the way that is still not
uh uh
creating a world in which you weren't
designed with biological limitations i
understand what you're saying you've
managed to
use surgical mode you know modern
surgical medical advancements to maybe
change your height it's not the same
thing as claiming you weren't born a
certain
no
that's where we differ definitely the
difference is you weren't physically
that way
but in your mind you know you may be
something different you know if you
decide tomorrow you want blonde hair you
go dye your hair yeah you weren't blonde
but maybe but we're not talking about
blonde haired guys competing against
comparison yeah but it's not i would say
it's not a valid comparison when we're
discussing i think look i think
i appreciate what you're what you're
saying
and i do think that you're right that
they're going to be as a matter of fact
i've talked about this if you can live
probably another 30 40 years
you'll be a part of a generation that
can live significantly longer or
probably never much longer than 120
years old but live healthily sure until
your later age i mean even right now
we're seeing with like hormone
replacement therapy as you get older um
as a matter of fact that's a big problem
when it's also a problem with uh you
know
transgender hormone replacement therapy
because we know how cancer genic it is
no it's not debatable we know that if
you uh inject estrogen or you provide
excess estrogen to the male uh endocrine
system that it's not good as a matter of
fact you know what the first thing is if
you're a woman with high estrogen levels
and
if you're women you have breast cancer
first thing they put you on
i i just aromatase inhibitors
i thoroughly enjoy that
i know everyone makes this point but you
do come to college campuses you know i'm
i'm pursuing my education well we do
this by the way we also do this not on
college campuses i understand but you
know the ones that go popular the reason
you keep coming back is for the college
ones
so we actually do just as many on street
corners i'm sure you do just as many yes
but what do we do today in 2022 with
male and female sports i cannot say i'm
not a female i'm not transgender i'm i'm
not you know in these sports okay but
let's say overwhelming majority of
females say it's not fair
but then transgenders this is where we
are
biological men biological males who say
that they are
uh the woman gender say well i want to
compete with biological females what the
biological females say no it's not fair
what do we do
i
i can't say you know these these type of
rules and things but there do need to be
rules
of course there has to be rules to this
world so what's the solution
i can't say okay i'd like to understand
that we can't live in a world where
that's the case there does that we do
have to have rules this current world
is is is a testing ground for tomorrow
you know everything we do today is just
going to affect how we do so what do we
do today
okay so then i will just say i'll hang
my balls out there and it's very cold
outside so they're they're going to be
tiny raisinets uh we do it the way we've
always done it and we do it in
accordance with what most biological
female athletes want uh biological males
regardless of how you identify
compete with biological males biological
females compete with biological females
i think
i understand exactly what you're saying
and your point could directly be
compared to women's suffrage
you know males at the time of women
servers wanted you know
they wanted it to be the way it was
actually that's not true did you know
that
i don't believe it yeah did you know
that actually it was a majority of women
didn't want the right to vote did you
know that i can't confirm your
statistics yeah well let me explain to
you why actually it's very interesting i
had a lady named karen straughan on the
show and this is kind of her special
yeah karen strong yeah i know her name
is karen strong um and she is she's a
feminist
and the reason for this was well first
off women's suffrage right you're
talking about women getting the right to
vote how'd that happen
of course the voice of women to be heard
how did women get the right to vote
the women's voters voices were hurt
okay how are they hurt
you know i can't answer those questions
exactly
so you're just trying to embarrass me no
no i'm really not
men were the exclusive
right holders to voting right women were
not allowed to vote right okay
then women were allowed to vote
so there was a change so we changed it
change was made by the human race
change was made by men
women didn't have a say in the vote if
they could vote right my point is no my
point is this is a misrepresentative
this is a misrepresentation that men
females well no my point here is this is
a misrepresentation and i think it
matters because if you don't understand
history fully you're doomed to repeat it
right the majority of men
said
males we use the term males because back
then of course they wouldn't even have a
chip in their brain for modern gender
theory but men's men voted to give women
the right to vote the reason that a
majority of women didn't want the right
to vote because a lot of people don't
understand this historically now i'm not
saying that women shouldn't have the
right to vote just to be clear i'm just
explaining the historical context
voting came with certain
responsibilities like the draft
like owning property like paying taxes
like bucket duty which was mandatory
voluntary firefighter service and women
said oh if that's what we have to do to
vote we don't want it
and then men
had
the vote for them to vote and said by
the way you don't have to do any of that
stuff only the men do
so a lot of people don't understand that
that's a big reason what you're saying
yeah i think that
obviously it changed over time there was
there was a testing period which i would
say we were in now comparatively
and it changed over time to benefit
what i would say with the majority of
people
does this become normalized now i mean
how can you say it it didn't benefit us
yeah i think women script the votes
sometimes
interesting i don't agree with you
that's okay
i certainly think women should have the
right to vote but uh
yeah i think we've seen some bad votes
and i think we've seen some buyer's
remorse from women voting
them voting where they're like well you
know what this is like we've talked
about women who thought well it's okay
for the trans issue and now they go uh
awesome we can't have them competing in
our sports it's like well
look behind you there's a slippery slope
however i do think it's one thing this
is this is the beauty of college campus
is you're dealing in the sort of
nebulous right like well this and maybe
tomorrow there does need to be a
solution today
and if you're talking about something
that involves biological differences
right physiological differences which
can cause actual harm not to mention
even removing opportunities from
biological females
you stick with the rules that you have
and if you want to create a third
division let that be the experimenting
run not of the cost not of the cost of
women's opportunities that's why title
ix exists i believe there shouldn't be
any discrimination no matter who the
person is
so you consider a biological male
if the sporting organization the
governing body says you have to compete
with biological males or in a third
division an inter-gender division but
not with biological females you see that
as discrimination yes absolutely okay so
your solution isn't to let biola so you
do have a solution is to let biological
males compete with women i think i could
compare your points of mind where uh
that you'd seen in the black segregation
right in a while segregation okay yes or
any color people in the united states
there's a different baseball league for
both would you not call that
discrimination
yeah of course that's discrimination by
definition yeah and then all of a sudden
when the uh you as i can say this
because uh
former vice president joe biden said at
the united negro league once they uh
mixed it guess what there weren't too
many great white baseball players i
believe they're sons there are some but
the point is it's the point is they
wanted to keep him out because we knew
that there was some black speed and
power my friend i feel like that's
extremely racist
really to say that black people are
better athletes than white people in
certain sports i think so yeah really
have you watched an nba game
i'm not going to say either way is it
racist to say that the majority of the
nba is black
is it racist for me to say that black
people are typically better at
basketball than the average white person
i
i guess by definition it's racist but i
don't think that you would find a single
black person here disagree
i think that's a pretty broad point
you're making
and obviously i'm not one to say i'm not
a person
but you just said it's racist so you did
speak on behalf of black people
absolutely to say that black people are
they make up a higher percentage of the
nba than white people
to say that they're
that's not what you said
in general sure what did you exactly let
me give you a different one in general
black people black males
at the elite level are faster than white
males
i feel like this is a racist statement
have you checked any of the land speed
records i i don't know this look at the
top ten you're not gonna find a
whittaker
you're not gonna find an irish last name
you don't agree
with the world records
my statement that at the elite level
black males tend to run faster times
than white males that's not what you say
at the elite level black males are
faster than white males
that's that's not what you originally
said that is what i said in this past
point but earlier your statement was the
characteristics of black people versus
any other person that
black people tend to be more successful
in athletics than white people yes i'm
not saying the statistics are racist i'm
saying your statement regarding black
people is
based on statistics
that doesn't matter and certainly not
it's certainly not inferring that
they're inferior
are we not leaving that's maybe what you
are for
that
that all the land speed records that all
the 100 meter dash records are held by
black people and not white people that
that's racist that's not what i'm saying
how is that suggesting they're inferior
the statistics aren't racist okay
i'm saying your statement was
okay so how do i address the statistic
that all land speed records you're
saying all right you don't have to get
carriers
but that is what i said you still said
it was racist
no i was referring to yours okay so how
do i say
all of the top land speed records on on
two feet
uh at the elite level are held
exclusively by black males exactly i
just said it
so that's not racist
but it's racist for me to say that as a
general rule
in the elite category when you're
looking at the elite of the elite
runners black males are faster than
white males that's not racist that's
exactly
how did i state it the earlier statement
was you're describing uh obviously
with a little bit of racial motif in the
background uh black people's
characteristics
i don't understand what do you mean
racial motif in the background are you
trying to say that there's some kind of
an undertone that's racist
and a white person or people
right there don't need to be
clarifications on the differences
but i was addressing a specific instance
of athletic capability you were and then
you went off on that little tangent and
then came back to it to try to cover it
i never addressed
the differences between black and white
people outside of athletics you didn't
context you said
you gave characteristics of black people
being faster
you give different characters more
athletic in general
what characteristics did i get i can't
repeat things
because they didn't they were never set
they were saying well the good thing is
here we have a loop what did i say i
don't understand what i'm trying i can't
say i remember saying black people were
more athletic right more athletic faster
i said speed and power
right i'm talking about baseball are you
talking about united negro league no no
no
that's obviously a term that was
so i i can't possibly
i'm saying not in the word itself but
the way you stated it is racism
okay so it's not the word it's the way i
stated it that uh in general the elite
black athletes are faster than the elite
white athletes
you could say that yeah but you believe
that's right okay so you believe that's
racist that's fine we just disagree on
that and i don't i don't
see that as something that most black
people would disagree with uh but we can
ask some we can find something here yeah
sure
i think that you're i think that um
i think one thing that i will say is
first off i appreciate you sitting down
aside from the accusation of racism or
saying that the statement was made in a
way that you believe was racist aside
from that i think you've kept it
remarkably civil uh
but i will say i don't think this has
been very productive i i don't believe
so either and the reason is because you
live
especially on college campus
you are afforded the luxury of not
having to offer solutions in the real
world
and there aren't many places where
that's the case well because you don't
deal with these consequences right now
you're pursuing your education
you're obviously taken aback by
something else well i think that's
actually a discriminatory thing to say
how do you say it what about someone who
decided not to go to a university or
college but someone who's creating a
business someone is learning a trade are
they not pursuing an education
no they are pursuing an education
absolutely but they don't get the deal
simply in the philosophical right they
have to answer pragmatically like wait
hold on a second there's a bottom line
to this profit wait hold on a second am
i doing this stuff correctly or i'm not
you're afforded a luxury of being able
to express ideas without bringing them
to their endpoint solution right so
that's a big purpose too to change my
mind ideas if you're going to change my
mind right and this is i'm not going to
change your mind that's why you sit down
but yeah you know
i think this is important what are you
studying cyber security engineering
was this throne or this fall oh okay i'm
used to objects
um
i think uh uh what are you studying
cyber security engineering cyber
security engineering yes oh okay so
that's a field where really quickly
you're gonna find out once you go into
the workforce if you're good or you're
bad at your job
yeah debatably
no not debatably it'll be f your ass
will be fired if some okay right if
you're what i'm saying if you're not
good you'll be fired
yeah yeah because it's it either worked
you either kept them secure you either
kept them secure you didn't that's not
it's not black and white like that
one's in series as an employer i can
tell you it is pretty black and white
jobs are performance-based no absolutely
right i understand not so much in in the
realm of higher education you know
there's situations that are maybe a boss
like that it wouldn't be up to you i'm
saying there's other options i didn't
say it would be up to me
i mean
i think you're doing the word salad
thing which i know is very fun to do in
universities and colleges but
you're saying it wouldn't be up to you i
never said it was up to me what i was
saying is that there's going to be an
objection as a boss you as a boss right
a boss will determine if your job is
good or bad if you had a bad day maybe
you fired somebody that's not up to the
person
it's just one except for the employer
sagan it's up to the employer through
objective parameters set if you're good
at your job or not
whereas that doesn't really apply here
right
on college there are grading systems
okay but if i were a professor
and i was grading you on solutions
provided you'd have to get a zero
percent you could be biased
i'm sure i could be biased i would argue
that you haven't presented any solutions
you just because you've said you don't
have them yeah i do not i'm a white male
but in order to well it's not because
you're a white male i believe it is
that's not why you don't have any
solutions my friend don't hide behind
don't hide behind the white male thing
it is to say that you're a white male
therefore you don't have solutions you
can still present one no i'm saying you
have a dog in the fight enter the arena
especially if you especially if you are
going to change someone's mind
especially if you're going to convince
someone to your point of view you do
need to offer
some kind of a quantifiable solution and
that's how the world works now i've done
that and i know you i don't even
necessarily know that you fully agree or
disagree i just know that you don't
really know what it is that you think
should be done
and i think that that's i agree i think
that's honestly representative
well there is when it harms people in
the real world being over confident is
also
a source of damage yeah i don't think
that saying biological men biological
males compete with biological males and
biological females compete with again
likewise uh i don't think that's a
problem with overconfidence i think if
so oh my gosh doctors and
epidemiologists and physiologists and
biologists are cocky as [ __ ] so uh but
man i do appreciate you sitting down
jackson
jackson
see my talk with jackson really
highlights the problem with universities
and how the obfuscation of objective
truth
really absolves students
of providing concrete answers to real
issues in the real world now jackson
isn't a bad kid and i do appreciate him
sitting down with me but the lack of
argument or ability to even articulate
an objective position is exactly where
institutions like unt have failed
students in the first place at unt no
less the harvard of denton county now if
you want to see more of these smash the
like button and comment below which
topic you'd most like to see covered
next and if you think this video has
helped you understand this topic better
please consider sharing it
and subscribing or tuning in tomorrow at
10 a.m eastern see you there
you